nous accueillons à présent Monsieur
Jean-Pierre siuta président de la
Fédération Française de BasketBall et
Monsieur Alain coutano directeur général
messieurs je vous souhaite la bienvenue
et vous remercie de votre disponibilité
pour répondre à nos questions nous avons
entamé les travaux de cette commission
d'enquête sur l'identification des
défaillances de fonctionnement au sein
des fédérations françaises de sport du
monde sportif et des organismes de
gouvernance du monde sportif le 20
juillet dernier nos travaux portent sur
trois axes les violences physiques
sexuelles ou psychologique dans le sport
les discriminations sexuelles et
raciales et les problématiques liées à
la gouvernance financière des organismes
de gouvernance du monde
sportif monsieur le Président vous avez
confondé le club féminin de Tarbe dont
vous êtes l'administrateur de 1986 à
1995 président de la Ligue féminine de
basketball de 2001 à
2009 vous êtes désigné premier
vice-président chargé du pôle haut
niveau de la f fédération française au
basketball en janvier 2009 vous êtes élu
président de la
FBB la FFBB pardon en novembre 2010
réélu en 2012 2016 et 2020 il s'agit
ainsi de votre 4e mandat à la tête de la
fédération membre du Comité national
olympique et sportif français à partir
de 2013 vous en démissionner en 2019
invoquant des raisons personnelles
Monsieur le Directeur Général
initialement chargé de mission sur les
sports professionnels puis en charge de
l'évaluation des fédérations sportives
au sein de la Direction des Sports du
ministère des Sports de 1993 à 2005 vous
devenez par la suite adjoint au DTN de
la Fédération française de tennis en
2010 vous rejoignez la Fédération
Française de Basket en tant
qu'entraîneur national et DTN adjoint
vous êtes directeur général et directeur
technique national de la de la FFF
depuis 2008 2018 pardon messieurs dans
un bref prop liiminaire pouvez-vous nous
dire quels sont les faits dont la
Fédération Française de BasketBall a eu
à connaître dans le champ de cette
commission et la manière dont elle y a
répondu quelles sont les éventuelles
difficultés auxquelles vous êtes
confronté dans le traitement de ces
affaires et dans l'application du cadre
je rappelle que cette audition est
ouverte à la presse et qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale avant de vous
laisser la parole et d'entamer nos
échanges je vous rappelle que l'article
6 de l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative aux fonction des assemblées
parlementaires impose aux personnes
entendues par une commission d'enquête
de prêter serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité rien que la vérité je
vous invite donc chacun à votre tour à
lever la main droite à dire je le jure
après avoir activé votre
micro je le
jure je le jure merci messieur vous avez
donc la
parole merci madame la présidente Madame
la rapporteur madame Messieurs les
Députés élu depuis 1996 j'attends ma
dernière année au service du du sport
français la nouvelle équipe sera en
place à partir du 14 décembre 2024 nous
mettons tout en œuvre pour relever le
défi des jeux de paris 2024 avec déjà
trois équipes sur qu qualifié je propose
de vous présenter rapidement notre
fédération naissance en 1932 3800 clubs
affiliés un nombre de licenciés en
progression de 450000 en 20100 à 725000
en 2020 3 dont 35 % féminine et c'est un
record historique dans la même période
le budget passé de 20 à 40 millions
d'euros le soutien de l'État est passé
lui de 2,4 à 4,4 million d'euros et le
nombre de CTS en réduction de 74 à
57 forte progression du personnel
fédéral nous sommes passés de 90 à 147
salariés pour 139 ETP nous avons deux
disciplines olympiques le basket 55 et
le basket 33 depuis Tokyo
2020 un nombre de médailles en forte
progression 51 à fin 2010 et 97
supplémentaires depuis 2011 60000
équipes engagées dans ces compétitions
annuelles 500000 rencontres officielles
un développement important du basket 33
en extérieur un développement intérieur
des pratiques non compétitive au sein de
ce que nous appelons le vivre ensemble
basket santé basket inclusif microbasket
et eSport nous avons 5 filiale une
activité commerciale en plein
développement qui s'appelle less Factory
nous avons une ligue professionnelle la
LNB et une ligue féminine la LFB nous
avons 16 équipes engagées dans des
compétitions européennes nous avons 14
joueurs français à nB Dans le jeune
prodige Victor W wembama
excusez-moi la Fédération a été
récemment contrôlée par l'URSAF en
2019-2020 par l'Inspection générale
2022-223 et puis par l'Agence Française
antiorruption en
2022-2023 nous tenons à votre
disposition ces trois rapports la
Fédération ayant comme toujours la ferme
volonté de progresser enent tenant en
compte les observations et
préconisations relevé lors de ces rang
contrôles les nouveaux statuts de la
fédération ont été votés lors de
l'assemblée générale ordinaire du puit
du Fou en octobre dernier ces statuts
sont conformes à la loi de mars 2022 à
ce jour un comité d'EUR composé de 35
membres dont 14 femmes un bureau fédéral
composé de 16 membres se vice-présidents
dont trois
vice-présidentes j'ai l'honneur de
présider cette fédération depuis le 13
novembre 2010 et ce sera mon dernier
mandat seul élu rémunéré je suis mise à
disposition par mon employeur avec un
remboursement intégral des salaires j'ai
également un complément fédéral ces
rémunérations sont conformes au statut
de la Fédération au code du sport et
bien sûr au code général des impôts les
services opérationnels sont organisé au
sein d'une direction générale et de SEP
pôle opérationnel à noter que le
pilotage politique et opérationnel est
assuré parendem vice-président directeur
de pôul ce qui permet un meilleur suivi
de l'entreopolitique fédérale malin
contensou qui m'accompagne il est un
agent l'étaat je dirais même un grand
serviteur de l'étaat du sport français
il est nommé à la Fédération depuis
avril 2010 est nommé
dtndg depuis janvier 2018 je souhaite
maintenant vous présenter la
contribution de notre fédération en lien
avec les trois sujets la commission
d'enquête parlementaire si vous le
souhaitez chaque point évoqué pourra
être développé plus en détail premier
point que je souhaite évoquer c'est le
contrat de délégation et notre stratégie
nationale la loi du 24 août 2020 met fin
à la tutelle de l'État pour sur les
fédérations instaure un nouveau contrat
de délégation et impose à chaque
fédération d'élaborer sa stratégie
nationale la Fédération signe son
contrat le 30 mars 2022 qui valide sa
stratégie nationale le premier la
première évaluation des fédérations est
en cours nous avons envoyé nos document
le 23 juin 2023 et nous avons calé un
temps d'échange avec la directrice des
sports le 6 décembre
prochain 2è point les instances
concernées et les ressources humaines
mobilisées sur ce sujet je citerai
d'abord le comité directoire fédéral et
le Bureau fédéral qui joue un rôle
décisionnaire nous avons une commission
fédérale de discipline cet organe
disciplinaire indépendant de première
instance investi d'un pouvoir
disciplinaire à l'égard des associations
affiliées dé licenciés et tout membres
de ces associations agissant en qualité
de dirigeant ou de licenciés de fait
elle est régie par par règlement
disciplinaire général conforme au
règlement type pris en Conseil d'État et
validé par le ministère des Sports le
règlement évolué en 2017 puis en 202 de
pour notamment sécuriser des procédures
de violence sexuelle en agissant en
élargissant les les les infrastructures
pardon les infractions susceptibles de
faire l'objet de de dossierers
disciplinaires jusqu'à prévoir
spécifiquement l'infraction d'avoir
délibérment menti dans le renseignement
des informations permettant la mise en
œuvre du contrôle d'honorabilité nous
avons une chambre d'appel
elle est indépendante et chargé
d'examiner les recours contre la quasi
intégralité des décisions prises par les
commissions fédéral et les organismes
déconcentrés délégataires exemple la
Ligue Nationale de Basket elle est un
préalable interne obligatoire à la
saisie des juridiction elle comprend
trois sections administrativ avec 24
membres disciplinaires 25 membres et
financière avec 25 membres nous avons
comité d'éthique la loi de mars 2017
impose à chaque fédération la
constitution d'un comité d'éthique et
l'établissement le cas échéant avec sa
ligue professionnelle d'une charte
éthique le comité éthique du basket a
été créé en 2018 et la charte éthique
élaborée conjointement avec la Ligue
nation de basket est entré en vigueur le
12 juillet
2018 la cellule signalement FFBB cré en
septembre 2020 elle est composée de 4
personnes Christophe responsable du
service d'intégrité et référent violence
sexuelle désigné auprès du ministère
nous avons al est un chargé de mission
au service inégrité nous avons claire
Sam qui est juriste au serviceintégrité
nous avons ici présente qui du P
nous avons une cellule de mise en
concurrence créée dans la volonté de
respecter des recommandations de laafa
elle a été composée de 6 personnes donc
deux élus deux cadres d'État trois
cadres de droit privé dont le
responsable de service d'intégrité
conformité nous mobilisons aussi
beaucoup de ressources humaines nous
évaluons à peu près entre 200 et 250
dirigeants bénévoles plus l'intégralité
des services donc cadre technique et
d'état et salariés sur tous les sujets
au sein de la fédération et tout le
réseau fédéral à noter que notre
direction des affaires juridiques
institutionnelles avec sa directrice ici
présente
comporte 17 collaborateurs dont
plusieurs référents ou délégués agents
sportif intégrité violence sexuelle
honorabilité lutte antidopage dans un
avers très proche dans un avenir très
proche choix d'un lanceur d'alerte
demandé par la FA et d'un Spock ce qu'on
appelle un Spock c'est un single point
of contact qui permet de faire le lien
avec la Fédération Internationale ces
deux missions sont actuellement assurées
par le délégué
intégrité 3è point la prévention et la
communication au titre de la prévention
contre les violences sexuelles le
bisutage je citerai le premier
partenariat avec colosse au pied
d'argile signé en 2017 en pleine
assemblée générale à SaintÉtienne son
renouvellement en 2022 qui permet
d'aller plus loin depuis 2017 37
interventions par ka diffusion d'un kit
papier CAPA donc en 2021 puis un kit
numérique téléchargeable en 2022 des
formations fédérales comme stand standup
agissant contre leurcement de rue vivre
ensemble à diversité module
antiorruption ou encore sur les
violences et discrimination lors des
forums FFBB citoyen nous avons fait en
2018 2020 2022 2024 un module de 7 he
porté sur la prévention des violences
sexuelles des temps annuels de formation
sur les territoires lors des
regroupements des dirigeants en région
la communication féérale via le site
internet l'intrnet fédéral qui permet de
consulter et télécharger toutes les
ressources disponibles un e-learning
gratuit accessible à tous une vidéo
d'engagement de 2 minutes 30 une
commission dédiée société mixité qui
travaille sur la prévention autour de
cet axe une une sollicitation de trois
référents nationaux l'affichage des
numéros d'aide aux victimes dans chaque
gymnase sujet abordé avec Landes neu
note d'information vers le réseau et les
clubs et un guide quatre pages sur les
outils de prévention des violences
sexuelles l'ination faite au stade des
équipes de France au cadre d'État dans
les poil espoir la Fédération soutient
ses actions au titre du projet sportif
fédéral PSF financé par la ns c'était
250000 € en 2021 c'était 340000 € en
2022 mais également sur ses fonds
propres à hauteur de 191000 pour cette
saison au titre des actions menées suite
au rapport AFA nous pouvons citer donc
la cartographie des risques est en cours
et derrière les règles de déport 4è
point que je souhaite évoquer c'est les
procédures concernant le signalement
nous avons trois modes de signalement et
de saisine le signalement par la victime
les structures fédérales ou le
signalement par la cellule du ministère
des des sports et CAPA ou les
découvertes d'informations jeis souhaite
rentrer dans le détail sur les trois
modes de signalement le signalement par
les par la victime ou les structures
fédérales la Fédération reçoit et traite
toutes les demandes qu'elle reçoit
qu'importe le formalisme avant septembre
2020 les signalements étaient
majoritairement effectués par téléphone
et confirmé par mail à la Fédération
depuis le le 28 septembre 2020 la
désignation de référent dédier la de FDB
donc a créé une adresse mail dédier qui
s'appelle signalement @ffb com et une
page internet sur le site fédéral
deuxème point deuxème choix donc le
signal le signalement de la cellule par
la cellule le ministère des sport ouapa
les les services de la Fédération
ouvrent très régulièrement avec la
transmission des signalements dont des
information relative au prononcer des
mesures d'incapacité ou d'arrêter
suspension d'exercice la cellule dédiée
du ministère dans des sports signal
sport le le si honorabilité du ministère
des Sports pour les retours liés à le
contrôlehonorabilité Ka par
l'utilisation des fich navettes
aujourd'hui remplacé par une plateforme
de signalisation quand nous découvrons
les informations la Fédération effectue
donc une veille pardon le 3ème choix la
Fédération effectue donc une une veille
de presse régionale et informe le
secrétaire général la cellule du
ministère et le caschi en ka lorsqu'elle
découvre des faits concernant ses
licenciés susceptibles de faire l'objet
d'une mesure ou d'une procédure
disciplinaire également par le biais de
réquisition judiciaire d'échange avec
les officiers de police judiciaire toute
identification de de faits pouvant faire
l'objet d'une éure est enclenchée en
résumé pas de plateforme spécifique
dédié au sein de la fédération un alli
spécifique depuis 2020 réception et
traitement de toutes les demandes
qu'importe le la
manière le traitement des signalements à
réception d'anciennement des échanges
préalables interviennent
systématiquement entre les les parties
concerné don victime ou ses
représentants président du comité
départemental ou le club concerné et le
référent de la Fédération possibilité de
mise en relation par la accompagnement
auprès de Ka et de l'assureur fédérale
qui prendra le relais pour accompagner
la victime ou le club la cellule du
ministère des Sports est
systématiquement informé des éléments
portés à la connaissance de la
Fédération échange régulier avec les
référents dans le cadre de procédure
judiciire d réception de récipiss de
dépôt de plainte le référent prend tâche
auprès de l'officier de police
judiciaire au préalable pour ne pas
interférer dans une une enquête en cours
exemple ouverture d'un dossier
disciplinaire o une mesure fédérale
pourrait conduire à une personne
surveillée de les preuves des
correspondances auprès du Procureur de
la République compétent peuvent être
adressé en fonction des dossiers
jusqu'en août 2022 le secrétaire général
informé saisissait la la commission
fédérale discipline pour traitement du
dossier depuis le 24 août 2022 le Bureau
fédéral a a a décidé donc une autre
manière quand une personne est
pénalement sanctionnée la Fédération
entire les conséquences par l'ouverture
d'un dossier disciplinaire et le cas
échéant par la prise d'une sanction
disciplinaire appropriée quand une
procédure judiciaire est en cours n'a
donc pas encore fait l'objet d'un
jugement le Bureau fédéral peut
prononcer une mesure administrative
conservatoire sur la la situation du
licencié dans l'attente d'une décision
d' mesure de justice en application du
principe de précaution et de protection
des licenciés aussi lorsque la
fédération est informée par le ministère
des Sports des notifications d'arrêté
préfectur d'interdiction d'exercice et
d'incapacité donc correspondant un
signalement identifié au non le Bureau
fédéral peut être amené à prononcer donc
une mesure administrative conservatoire
l'accompagnement des victimes et
structure fédérale dans le cadre de son
partenariat CAPA accompagne les victimes
et les structures fédérales concernées
la Fédération a également prévu lors du
dernier renouvellement de son contrat
d'assurance collectif la possibilité
pour les licenciés victimes de de
bénéficier de garanties notamment
juridique en matière d'accompagnement
psychologique les difficultés pratiques
et juridiques il y a renforcement des
actions et communications de tous les
acteurs engagés dans cette lutte la
confidentialité des procédures et le
transfert de données sensibles les
moyens humains la réactivité peuvent
être de nature à ralentir la
transmission des bonnes informations
avant de prendre les mesures idoines si
procédures judiciaires reconnues par la
Fédération nous adressons une une
correspondance au procureur pour
proposer dans notre concours dans le
cadre d'une procédure pour obtenir des
informations pour mettre en œuvre le cas
échéant des mesures nécessaires de
veiller au principe de précaution et de
sécurité des des des licenciés le
contrôle honorabilité il insiste il
consiste à un cro de ficher avec la
figess le figes pardon depuis la loi de
d'O 2021 2021 nous contrôlons également
le corps arbitral par un process
informatique c'est désormais par date de
qualification des licenciés que nous
sont effectués ces contrôles je vous
parler de la gestion d'un dossier de
violence sexuelle si la Fédération
reçoit un signalement de violence
sexuelle et en synthèse de la première
contacte mise en relation s accorde la
personne remontant les fait avec Ka le
simple témoignage de la personne ne
suffit pas à déclencher la procédure
disciplinaire ou administrative si
souhait de ne pas déposer plainte nous
recherchons des éléments complémentaire
pour permettre le cas échant la
fédération de prendre toutes mesures
visant à protéger ses licenciés tout en
respectant le principe de présomptionés
je vais devoir vous interrompre parce
que tout simplement je pense qu'on a de
nombreuses questions à vous poser et que
en répondant à ces questions on va
revenir sur tous les sujets que vous
abordez comme vous le souitez donc pour
éviter de faire doublon peut-être que ça
sera plus sympathique et interactif de
faire ce ce ce jeu de questions-réponsse
et on sera mieux compris j'imagine très
bien peut-être laisser aussi oui vous
avez aussi une intervention je vous en
prie Monsieur le
Directeur madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés je vais commencer par une
première réflexion issue de 50 ans de
pratique sportive et de plus de 30 ans
au service du ministère des Sports pour
lequel j'ai la chance de travailler
chance car il est précieux d'allier
activité professionnelle et passion le
sport est un secteur particulier dans
lequel se croisent d'une part des
bénévoles suffisamment passionnés pour
s'investir heure après heure pour faire
vivre des associations qui permettent à
des jeunes ou moins jeunes de pratiquer
leur passion d'autre part des
professionnels soit issu de la fonction
publique dont le recrutement concerne
principalement des pratiquants confè les
conditions de recrutement des
professeurs de sport et l'accession au
concours réservés aux sportifs et
sportifs de haut niveau soit des
salariés de droit privé dont la plupart
ont été formé dans un cursus dédié au
sport cette commission d'enquête vise à
établir les dysfonctionnements des
acteurs délégataires de servicees public
dans le sport secteur qui malgré cette
passion qui l'entoure n'échappe pas aux
dérives de la société preuve en est le
travail réalisé par la civice commission
indépendante sur l'inceste et les
violences sexuelles faites aux enfants
créés en 2021 par le Président de la
République les conclusions des travaux
intermédiaires sont terribles ils font
en effet état de 160000 enfants qui sont
victimes de violences sexuelles chaque
année 5,4 millions de femmes et d'hommes
adultes en ont été victimes dans leur
enfance nous devons bien évidemment
œuvrer collectivement à la sécurisation
du sport et bien au-delà le sport c'est
15,4 millions de licenciés dont plus de
la moitié sont des mineurs soit un peu
plus d'un5e de la population française
nous sommes donc tous concernés pour
revenir sur la Fédération Française de
BasketBall cette concomitance de
bénévoles et de salariés dont je parlais
initialement animé par la même passion
est une des vraies forces qui porent les
actions menées quel que soit le domaine
par la FFBB quelques chiffre cette
fédération est passée d'un budget de
presque 20 millions en 2010 à 41
millions d'euros en 2023 soit une
progression de plus de 100 % les trois
pôles d'activité qui ont le plus
progressé étant le haut niveau la
formation et l'administration générale
affairire juridique dans le même temps
le nombre de cts fondait à vue d'œil
puisque nous étions 74 en 2010 et sommes
désormais 57 à date entre-ettemps nous
avons obtenu la délégation d'une
discipline supplémentaire le 33 devenu
olympique en 2017 et ainsi doubler notre
nombre de sélections nationales
désormais 22 sélections nationales plus
de 120 encadrants et près de 3 360
athlètes tous les étés en plus des
championnats classiques du basket 55 la
Fédération a développé une offre de
pratique dédiée au 33 et organiser près
de 2000 tournois avec 75000 pratiquants
au niveau départemental régional ou
national lors du dernier
été dans le même temps nous avons réussi
en quelques années à maintenir des
résultats de trèsut niveau en basket
tout en atteignant ce même niveau en 3-3
je rappelle qu'au derniers Jeux
Olympiques de Tokyo nous obtenions une
médaille d'argent avec l'équipe
masculine de basket une médaille de
bronze avec l'équipe féminine de basket
et une 4e place avec notre équipe
féminine 3-3 dans le même temps sous
l'impulsion du Président et son comité
directeur le vivre ensemble est venu au
cœur de nos objectifs ce vivre ensemble
qui nous conduit à développer des
actions dans le domaine de la mixité de
l'insertion de la santé et du loisir
pour accompagner ces évolutions tant sur
le haut niveau que pour le développement
la fédération est passée de 90 salariés
à 147 salariés pour
138,6 ETP nous avons donc tout en
développant toutes nos activités
embaucher et structurer
l'opérationnalité de la Fédération
malgré une une réduction je le rappelle
des cts placés auprès de la Fédération
je tiens je tiens à dire qu'il ne s'agit
pas ici de se plaindre d'un traitement
injuste mais de faire un constat sur
l'équilibre entre moyens public et
privés au sein de la fédération je dois
également ajouter que la part de
financement public au sein de la FFBB
atteint désormais environ 10 % de son
budget proportionnellement en réduction
quand bien même nos très bons résultats
nous permettent d'être accompagnés dans
nos projets novateurs tant par la
Direction des Sports que par l'ANS cette
évolution nous conduit à palier le
réduction du nombre de fonctionnaires
par une redistribution des missions et
un recrutement de cadres de droits
privés cadre à qui nous confions des
responsabilités importantes dans des
actions du projet de performance
fédérale du développement de la
formation de l'intégrité en clair dans
toutes les actions sont mentionné dans
le contrat de délégation signé le 30
mars
2022 cette coexistence entre
fonctionnaires et salariés de droit
privé est sans doute à la base de la
réflexion qui a conduit à construire le
poste de dtndg de la Fédération
garantissant ainsi une efficacité
évidente dans le traitement de tous les
champs d'activité de la Fédération je ne
reviendrai ici sur aucun des propos
tenus par Ludovique Royet qui a
parfaitement résumé ce qui justifie
pleinement ces missions conjointes de
DTN et de DG j'y ajouterai juste une
réflexion comp tenu de la réduction
progressive des moyens attribués par
l'État aux fédérations sportives
contribuant ainsi à les engager à
s'autonomiser sans pour autant réduire
le périmètre de leur mission conféré par
la délégation de service public il
devient plus que nécessaire que l'État
place auprès des fédération un cadre qui
puisse mobiliser autant les moyens
publics que ceux issus du secteur privé
on notera d'ailleurs la presse en est
largement paraî ces derniers temps que
les missions confiées à DTN peuvent être
largement contrarié par une organisation
mettant en tension celui-ci et un
directeur général il me semble avoir
compris que certaines fédérations
associent leur DG aux équipes de France
que la direction de la performance est
parfois parfois externalisé à la
Direction Technique Nationale je me
dépêche parfois partagé d'accord or la
performance nécessite une hiérarchie
claire une adaptation permanente donc
des décisions rapides que de multiples
interlocuteurs ne permet pas et que le
poste de DTN résout de fait les
résultats obtenus par la fédération en
terme de haut niveau de développement
mais également de structuration de la
fédération pour répondre aux enjeux du
sport français sont les fruits d'une
relation extrêmement forte entre le
président et le dtndg cette relation de
confiance permet une franchise qui
concourt à se dire les choses toujours
avec l'intérêt général au cœur des
réflexions pour en revenir au sujet si
dramatique des violence sexuelle ou
sexiste en particulier mais de toutes
les formes de violence d'abus d'autorité
de discrimination quelle qu'elle soit
sachez que nous avons adopté notre
organisation adaptée pardon notre
organisation à ce fléo ainsi nous avons
renforcé la prévention au sein du pôle
club et territoire dirigé par un DTN
adjoint et nous avons renforcé la
répression avec la nomination dans un
premier temps d'un référent intégrité
puis la création d'un service dédié qui
nous permet d'être réactif pour
combattre toutes ces formes de violence
en parallèle nous avons engagé dès 2019
une démarche d'accompagnement humain au
sein des structures fédérales confier la
formation de nos cadres dans ce domaine
à un expert procéder à une refondte de
la formation initiale de nos techniciens
en insistant sur la posture pédagogique
en créant des certificats de
spécialisation visant a mieux encadrer
les jeunes filles et garçons que les
parents nous confient en effet nous
avons tous conscience que des parents
nous confient leurs enfants dans les
clubs dans les structures fédérales en
sélection départementale régionale et ou
nationale je vais arriver à la fin c'est
une responsabilité bien comprise et
admise par les différents acteurs de
cette fédération un des principaux
arguments évoqués notamment dans les
structures du PF du du projet de
performance fédérale c'est la sécurité
de ses enfants c'est un message que nous
Renou nous voulons constamment la
prévisvention est évidemment un des axes
par exemple grâce aux interventions
régulières de colosse au pied d'argile
dans les pôles ou centre de formation ou
action mené avec le concours des
directions régionales académique à la
jeunesse à l'engagement et au sport les
dragess par exemple en organisant notre
PPF avec un mariage territorial fort de
pesoir permettant aux plus jeunes de
rentrer régulièrement chez eux et ainsi
conserver une relation forte avec leurs
parents je ne vais pas aborder la
répression le président l'a fait et je
crois que vous voulez nous nous nous
interroger dessus
je vais terminer en vous disant que la
FFBB ses élus et son personnel quel que
soit le statut sont animés par une
volonté collective qui se résume en deux
mots l'intérêt général c'est ce qui
guide l'ensemble des actions l'ensemble
des décisions et nous permet d'aborder
les différents enjeux qui se présentent
à nous avec détermination je vous
remercie je vous remercie messieurs pour
ces propos liminires un petit peu longs
certes mais euh mais en tout cas non
exhaustive sur le sur la FFBB et euh et
donc on vous remercie bien sûr je
voudrais revenir quand même sur un point
et vous en avez parlé Monsieur le
Directeur c'est euh on n'oublie pas que
la fédération de basket donc se
distingue des autres fédérations en ce
qu'une même personne donc vous-même
comme vous l'avez dit occupe à la fois
les fonctions de DTN de directeur
général et si cette situation elle est
bien sûr ancienne on l'a dit à la FFBB
euh réalisé en plein accord avec le
directeur des sports elle npparaît pas
conforme au cadre législatif et
réglementaire en vigueur pourquoi
refuser d'appliquer les règles alors je
ne sais pas à qui s'adresse cette
question si c'est plus au au président
qu'au directeur alors je je vais y
répondre très simplement ma lettre de
mission prévoit clairement la partie
direction générale donc c'est en plein
accord avec avec la Direction des Sports
euh et et le
ministère le le deuxième élément que je
peux apporter c'est que les choses ch
doivent évoluer madame la Présidente et
je suis très content que vous me posiez
cette question là parce que
effectivement je pense que avec la
réduction progressive des moyens de
l'État et néanmoins une augmentation des
missions bien légitimes pour palier à
beaucoup de de sujets dont celui
principal qui qui anime cette commission
effectivement il faut que l'ensemble des
moyens d'une fédération puisse être
mobilisé dans le cas d'un DTN DG c'est
le cas et c'est le cas beaucoup plus
facilement parce que on ne démultiplie
pas les les étapes et il y a un lien
hiérarchique extrêmement fort entre le
DTN et le ministère des sports avec la
ministre avec la directrice des sports
ce qui n'est pas le cas d'un directeur
général dont le lien hiérarchique est
seulement celui du
président monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente j'ai je
fais
partie des anciennes générations depuis
96 où j'ai connu moi une une DTN avec un
DTN et puis une direction générale avec
un directeur général c'était assez
compliqué la vie tous les jours pour
pour développer les actions c'était
quandme quand même pas simple
et et je pense qu'on a gagné en en
efficience ça nous a permis de de de
cranter la qualité des services et puis
bon le tout de suivi qu'on essaie de
faire ensemble avec le avec le le
gouvernement avec le ministère sur sur
développement de notre délégation
deuxième chose aussi que je veux dire
c'est que ça nous permet d'avoir quelque
part un un agent l'État bon qui qui est
un polyvalent c'est quelqu'un qui n'est
pas un spécialiste de notre sport et ça
c'est très important ça nous permet
d'avoir à côté de lui donc un un vrai
expert de notre sport ce qu'on appelle
donc directeur de la performance qui lui
tient toute la partie performance et
c'est vraiment ce que diten est vrai je
pense que c'est l'avenir voilà je pense
que on on présage ce que pour être
l'avenir de de nos de nos fédérations
merci pourquoi je vous pose cette
question bien sûr messieurs c'est que
cette pratique elle contevient par à à
au 2e alinéa de l'article L13 1311 du
code du sport bien sûr qui prévoit que
pendant la durée de leur mission les
conseillers techniques sportifs restent
placés selon le cas sous l'autorité
hiérarchique exclusive du ministère des
du ministerre chargé des sports ou du
chef de service déconcentré dont il
relève ils ne peuvent être regardés dans
l'accomplissement de le mission comme
lié à la Fédération par un lien de
subordination caractéristique du du
contrat de travail au sens du Livre 2 de
la première partie du code du travail
voilà pourquoi ma question alors je vais
vous rassurer je n'ai pas de contrat de
travail avec la Fédération et mon seul
lien hiérarchique encore une fois c'est
le
ministère madame la
rapporteur merci alors moi j'aimerais du
coup
comprendre puisque visiblement
ça a pas l'air conforme au cadre
législatif et réglementaire en fait
est-ce que le ministère des Sports vous
a dit d'y mettre fin à cette situation
ou est-ce que c'est totalement en accord
avec le ministère des sport et la
direction totalement en
accord dans un premier temps je vais
revenir peut-être sur
l'histoire madame la rapporteur puisque
vous me posez la
question lorsque j'ai été nommé
directeur technique national on m'a
demandé de de faire une demande de
complément de rémunération pour le poste
de directeur général et ensuite ça a été
modifié par la Direction des Sports en
accord avec la direction des sports donc
j'ai toujours respecté le cadre
législatif et j'ai toujours respecté les
consignes de ma
hiérarchie alors ça j'entends bien mais
du coup si vous n'êtes pas lié par un
contrat de travail avec la Fédération
euh qui vous paye aujourd'hui sur votre
salaire de DG euh la Fédération sur un
complément de rémunération comme
beaucoup de cadres d'État dans toutes
les fédérations
sportives pour dire que si demain le
ministère nous demande de cesser on
cessera c'est c'est très clair on a
aucun problème avec ça mais aujourd'hui
on considère que c'est c'est une vraie
une vraie qualité de de fonctionnement
est-ce que vous pourrez nous transmettre
la lettre de mission s'il vous
plaît
alors les membres du comité directeur et
ceux du bureau fédéral perçoivent-il des
jetons présence en contrepartie de leur
participation au réunions des organes
dont ils sont
membres exact ça a été relevé ça par le
par
l'Inspection générale de mémoire je
crois que c'est0 40 € oui pour les
membres du comité directeur c'est ça et
40 pour les membres du bureau fédéral
nous avons prévu de de de mettre ça
l'ORS du jour du prochain comité
directeur donc au mois de décembre
puisquà la demande de l'inpection g nous
devons cesser cesser ce type
de ce type de de fonctionnement comme on
dit vous avez une idée du montant que ça
représente à l'année ces 40 € de jeton
de
présence c'est vite calculé ils sont 35
multiplié par par 40 et donc il y a
quatre comités actcteur à l'année donc
vous avez le le calcul du comité
directeur donc peut-être faaire une une
calcul la politique relative à la mise à
disposition de carte bancaire a-t-elle
été supprimée ou à défaut revu pour être
plus fortement encadré
oui euh c'est exactement la démarche que
nous avons entrepris avec la
cartographie des risques et les
procédures que nous nous devons rédiger
en matière de de d'organisation
financière de telle sorte à renforcer à
renforcer le le la Fédération dans ce
domaine-là étant entendu que les deux
rapports que nous avons eu et cités par
le président en introduction euh on on
on présenter le fait que la Fédération
était très bien gérée donc on va on va
effectivement attendre la cartographie
des risques qui va être présentée le 15
le 15 décembre prochain en comité
directeur et ensuite nous allons rédiger
en fonction de cette cartographie des
risques des procédures qui seront
appliquées merci à vous dans son contrat
de délégation la Fédération s'engage à
mener une politique active visant à
féminiser les équipes d'encadrement
pouvez-vous nous développer les mesures
qui sont prises dans ce
sens je vais parler moi de la partie
peut-être
des élus de la gouvernance et puis
peut-être toi parler du travail que que
tu fais au niveau des des équipes de
France puisque il y a quand même une
volonté aussi de féminiser les STS des
équipes de France donc aujourd'hui bon
nous on a quand même un terreau de de
femmes qui font qui pratiquent le basket
avec 35 % aujourd'hui bon on a mis en on
a mis en comment sappelle no nos statuts
conformes donc à la loi de de mars 2022
et euh nous savons qu'en 2024 nous
serons la parité concernant le le comité
directeur c'est important donc moi je
serai je serai pas là pour gérer les
affair mais je pense que que derrière le
nouveau président ou la nouvelle
présidente cherchera effectivement à ce
que le Bureau Fédéral soit aussi
représenté avec une une parité ensuite
nous avons mis en place dans le cadre de
la commission société mixité donc des un
travail de faux sur sur l'approche
recrutement de nouvelles dirigeantes on
on en est à la 3è promotion va attaquer
la 3è promotion et aujourd'hui ça
fonctionne le VIè on trouve sur le
terrain des des euh des dirigeantes de
de grande qualité qu'on intègre de mieux
en mieux dans nos dans nos travaux donc
là-dessus je pense qu'on est euh on fait
un travail qui est quand même bon ça
fait partie des Gunes de notre
fédération et et ça fonctionne bien je
vais peut-être laisser euh me parler du
du reste alors clairement dans
l'encadrement euh sport pardon dans
l'encadrement sportif nous étions un peu
en retard et il y a une volonté très
forte affichée par la Fédération de
féminiser euh nos sélections nationales
notamment
puisque puisque jusqu il y a très peu de
temps à part Valérie Garnier qui était
la la la la coach de l'équipe de France
féminine l'ensemble des
autres équipe nationales était coaché
par des par des hommes euh cette année
encore nous avons commencé l'année
dernière à à à à à travailler sur ce
sujet pas que l'année dernière mais ça
s'est traduit ça a commencé à se
traduire l'année dernière parce que nous
sommes allés chercher des des des coachs
féminins qui uvraient sur le territoire
et on a on a au fur et à mesure encadré
de plus en plus d'équipes nationales
mais
aussi de de structure du du du Pôle
France et des pôespoir par des des
coachs féminines donc on est
véritablement on s'inscrit pleinement
dans cette démarche que nous avons
commencé fort tardivement mais pour
lequel nous nous inscrivons
pleinement BT nous sommes champions
d'Europe avec une une coach féminine
donc ça montre bien que ça c'est quand
même à dire et puis la Ligue féminine et
les équipes de France on les traite de
la même manière très sincèrement alors
c'est c'est c'est toujours très
compliqué de trouver des budgets mais
aujourd'hui au niveau des des équipes de
France féminines on les trait de la même
manière manière de se déplacer et cetera
et cetera donc il y a une forte volonté
de traiter la même manière de
genre alors
peut-être une question autour de de la
gouvernance et de la fédération en 2016
des tensions émerge autour du système de
vote dans votre dans votre fédération
pouvez-vous nous décrire cette période
et quels étaient les problèmes
identifiés ce que vous avez mis en place
suite à
cela pardon mais j'ai peur de ne pas
avoir compris la question des
problèmes mais en fait dans autour du
système de vote dans la fédération à ce
moment-là qui a conduit notamment à à
une rupture conventionnelle il me semble
avec le directeur des servicesination de
votre
fédération moi je peux parler des
élections par contre la partie
opérationnelle j'étais pas encoreéta pas
encore mais tu éta les affaires al très
très sincèrement bon les élections se
sont bien passées on a eu une opposition
comme c'est tout à fait tout à fait
cohérent mais derrière les bon
l'élection j'aiété élu je pense avec une
forte majorité on sortait quand même
d'une d'un bilan très très positif et
d'une Olympi très positive ensuite j'ai
pas moi souvenir qu'il y a eu des
problèmes liés à à à des je dirais des
problèmes d'élection de de de de service
informatique et cetera ce qui sûr c'est
que le jean-jaces cririf qui était le le
le responsable informatique n'est plus
fait partie de la maison mais après je
vois pas les relations de cause à effet
il y a pas eu de très sincèrement de de
notre part des des volontés de de je
dirais de ce qu'on peut appel la chasse
à la
sortière tu tu un plus et qu'est-ce qui
a conduit donc à cette rupture
conventionnelle à ce
départ si c'est une rupture
conventionnelle c'est qu'il y a un
accord des deux côtés donc une volonté
des deux
côtés je
je je je peux pas vous dire très
sincèrement donc on peut vous faire
passer la convention si vous
souhaitez puis voilà mais très
sincèrement j'ai aucun souvenir d'une
d'une situation je dirais
spéciale alors qui a pris sa suite sur
ce
poste euh c'est euh une jeune femme
ça à respecter alors je vais avoir du
mal à en parler puisque j'étais encore
une fois pas dtndg à l'époque mais
néanmoins j'étais présent à la
Fédération donc je pense que il y a
eu une fiche de poste qui a été ouverte
qu'il y a eu plusieurs candidats et que
le choix a été réalisé par par les
personnes en responsabilité sur ce
dossier euh voilà donc à l'époque
c'était le directeur du pôle affair euh
pas affaires juridique pardon du pôle
administration générale et finances qui
avait également les RH et le service
informatique c'est tout ce que je vais
pouvoir vous dire
là au niveau de la Fédération on nous au
niveau de la gouvernance nous
intervenons que sur les les recrutements
de directeurs de de pôul donc tout ce
qui a tout ce qui est en dessous donc
c'est un chef de service informatique
est traité directement par le le DG de
l'époque avec son avec son staff donc la
personne qui a été recrutée à la
direction des services informatiques
n'avait aucun lien avec la Fédération
avant l'AR avant son arrivée sur ce
poste elle n'avait pas eu affaire à la
Fédération ni travailler pour la
Fédération si si si bien sûr elle
faisait partie d'un cabinet de conseil
qui avait été sollicité et euh sur
l'outil informatique de la Fédération
voilà mais après il y a eu une ouverture
de poste plusieurs candidats je pense
qu'il on alors je je je
vais je pense qu' plusieurs candidats
ont été auditionnés et que et que le
choix s'est porté sur cette personne
mais encore une fois en s'agissant d'un
responsable de service
c'est le directeur du pôle concerné avec
le directeur général DTN de l'époque qui
ont fait ce choix là me
semble-t-il alors vous dites qu'elle
était dans un cabinet d'audit sur la sur
les questions informatiques et c'estàd
que elle a été amenée à faire des audits
sur votre service informatique avant de
devenir
directrice parler donc on a développé un
outil un outil MTI qu'on appelle FBI
donc on était sur une deuxè génération
de cet outil qui gère l'intégralité de
nos championnats donc le les désignation
des des arbitres et cetera les les les
convocations pour les matchs et cetera
et cetera donc c'est un gros dossier qui
a nécessité énormément de temps on avait
lancé à l'époque une consultation on a
choisi cette entreprise qui qui avait
fait ce dossier donc c'est pas une audit
de de l'informatique c'est un un outil
métier qui a été développé qui est pour
nous important puisque c'est un outil
qui nous permet de de gérer l'ensemble
de nos de nos activités comme la plupart
des
fédérations la semaine dernière des cris
de singes ont été adressés à des joueurs
du Paris Basket lors de leur match en
EUR Cup face à badalon si la Fédération
n'avait pas la capacité de sanctionner
ses comportements quelles sont les
mesures sur prise par la FFBB pour
lutter contre les propos racistes et
plus globalement discriminatoires dans
les
stades bon moi je peux vous dire ce
qu'on a fait nous suite à ce qui s'est
passé euh il y a qu' quelques jours donc
dès que nous l'avons appris bon moi j'ai
directement euh appelé le le président
du club et puis un des joueurs là qui
qui s'est manifesté pour le compte de de
de ces de ses coéquipiers pour dire que
on on condamne fermement ce type de ce
type de de situation nous avons fait un
communiqué presse en en suivant pour
soutenir le soutenir le club nous avons
dit que si le club avait besoin
d'engager des démarches avec la la
structure qui gère ces compétitions
européennes nous serons présents à côté
et j'ai envoyé moi un courrier
directement dans le de façon immédiate
et à à la Fédération espagnole donc est
au à la structure qui s'appelle le Roli
qui gère ses compétitions disant qu'il
faut condamner ce ce type de choses on
aa fait l'année dernière exactement la
même chose avec vidov dasask euh c'est
un club féminin qui avait joué donc une
coupe d'Europe aussi en Espagne qui
était dans la même situation avec le
même type de de comportement sur lequel
moi je me suis j'ai aussi manifesté j'ai
créé la FIBA Europe donc il a géré les
affaires puisqu'on était sur sur une
compétition féminine et d'ailleurs j'ai
j'ai j'ai donné tout mon soutien au au
président du du club donc ça c'est ça
c'est important après je sais pas si tu
vas me parler au moi sur la partie donc
de ce qu'on fait au niveau du du racisme
oui juste en terme de prévention ça ne
date pas de de ces
dernières mois puisqu'en 2018 nous avons
réalisé une vidéo contre le racisme la
vidéo notre victoire ce sont nos
différences et vidéo qui compte à ce
jour 138000 vues donc nous avons aussi
développer des actions de
prévention en matière de lutte contre le
racisme par l'intermédiaire de
de de de de notre service et et des
actions qui sont mené par la Commission
à mixité
euh au sein de la
fédération et pour poursuivre en janvier
2023 loï Akono joueur de mes a quitté le
terrain après avoir été insulté par un
spectateur les insultes avaient un
caractère raciste la Fédération avait
alors ouvert à un dossier disciplinaire
pouvez-vous revenir sur cette affaire et
sur la don vous l'avez
traité merci madame la
Présidente donc ça date de janvier 2023
c'est une rencontre de championnat de
National 2 donc c'est quelque chose que
nous gérons nous en en direct Oli qui
est un joueur que nous connaissons a été
je l'objet de de de traitement verbau on
parlait de
bolowo de suite on s'en est saisi moi
j'aiappelé directement et et et le
président du du club concerné mais
surtout le joueur lui dire que la
Fédération sera à ses côtés et nous
avons derrière donc nous fait de choses
un saisi la la commission fédérale
c'était 31 janvier 2 jours
après notification des des grifs et
convocation mise mise en cause devant la
commission fédérale le 1er février nous
avons notifié une mesure conservatoire
rencontre du club de charleseville mière
les rencontres l'équipe masculine
évoluant en championnat de National 2
donc ce jouron à H clos et nous avons
invité monsieur cono à participer donc à
à la disciplinaire du 22 février 2023 le
3 février nous avons notifié donc une
mesure conservatoire l'encontre les
arbitres puisque les arbitres considèent
ont été fautif sur la gestion de ce de
ce dossier interdiction d'exercice de la
fonction d'arbitre jusqu'à prononcer de
la
décision le 22 février don réunion la
commission fédérale les notifications de
la décision
fédérale qui est très simple le temps de
la retrouver nous avons décidé
d'infliger au club de charleseville
mière une rencontre à avec surcis
d'infliger donc un des deux arbitres une
interdiction d'exercice à la fonction
d'arbitre pour une durée de 3 semaines
ferme et une sortie de 3 semaines avec
surci et le deème arbitre dans
interdiction de de de de fonction
d'arbitre sur une durée de 6 semaines
ferme à sortie de 6 semaines avec surcis
nous avons fait le communiqué de presse
qui
pour confirmer toute cette demande et
surtout nous avons demander à ce qu'un
texte soit lu avant les rencontres donc
des des championnats de de France donc
ceex que je vais pas vous lire mais qui
reprend toutes nos valeurs et la volonté
de de de lutter contre le
racisme et d'une manière générale le
contrat de délégation qui lit la
fédération à l'état prévoit la mise en
œuvre d'une stratégie de je cite
prévention des violences incivilité et
discrimination détaillant des leviers
d'action les cibles de ces actions et et
les moyens associés pourriez-vous
développer les principaux axes de cette
stratégie
je alors
euh d'abord nous avons organisé
plusieurs commissions au sein de la
fédération euh d'abord la commission
nationale société mixité dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure euh qui travaille
sur la prévention autour de cet axe
basket sans violence prévenir des
violences dans et en dehors du sport
Basket respectueux sensibilisé à la
lutte contre les discriminations et
l'inclusion de tous les publics basket
laïque promouvoir les valeurs de la
République et la laïcité basket mixte
favoriser la place des femmes dans la la
pratique et au sein de toutes les
fonctions basket performant socialement
favoriser l'insertion de tous les
publics par et dans le sport Basket
responsable impliquer les acteurs et
actrices dans la transition écologique
enfin basket sain encour encourager un
mode de viin nous avons des relais
régionaux au sein de chaque ligue
régionale un référent ou une référente
société et mixité est nommé afin de
relayer les actions de la commission
nationale nous avons des des référents
nationaux euh aussi par la création d'un
pôle club et territoire qui intègre le
suivi des engagements sociétau de la
fédération et pour lequel nous avons au
sein d'une mission animée par Marie
wellell avec la l'appui de la commission
fédérale société et mixité dans le cadre
du Plan validé par le comité directeur
fvbb 2024 société et mixité de cadres
d'État missionnés Mathieu souchois
Olivier
Dalin concernant les relais d'action
nous avons euh des communication vers le
réseau je dénombre environ 9F sur les
dernières années
euh notes d'informations qui sont qui
sont établies et relayées sur sur
l'ensemble du territoire et sur
l'ensemble du réseau alors je vais
reprendre chronologiquement je vais
commencer en septembre 2020 pardon
sensibilité et prévention des violences
dans le sport le 29 septembre 18 janvier
2021 petit guide de lutte contre les
violences et discrimination dans le
sport 18 février 2022 renouvellement de
la convention CAPA 21 mars 2022 comment
lutter contre le racisme 7 décembre 2022
prévenir les violence sexuelle 3 février
2023 lutter contre les propos racistes 9
mars 2023 violence sexuelle 20 mars
2023 plan de lutte lutte contre les
incivilités pardon et puis nous avons
des campagnes de communication qui sont
réalisé par en fairplay un supporteur
insupportable laissz- les
jouer et la création d'un guide de 4
pages sur les les outils de prévention
des violences sexuelles et enfin
l'information au délégé des ligues et
des comités sur le forum de l'assemblée
générale depuis
nous faisons très régulièrement des
informations à l'ensemble des cts sur le
à l'occasion des séminaires qui sont
organisés et nous relayons ces
informations sur sur également les
encadrants des de nos structures
fédéral merci messieur la fédération
soit-ell des SIG allements de de
violence sexuelle et sexiste qui à
quelle fréquence et de quelle nature
sont ces violences s'il vous
plaît pardon
excusez-moi le signalement les modes de
signalement et de saisine le signalement
par la victime aux structures fédérales
la Fédération reçoit et traite toutes
les demandes qu'elle reçoit qu'importe
le formalisme avant septembre 2020 les
signalements étaient majoritairement
effectués par téléphone et confirmé par
mail à la Fédération et notamment au
secrétariat général de la Fédération au
service juridique ou à colosse au pied
d'argile qui conformément à notre
convention nous retransmettait
l'information depuis le 28 septembre
2020 et la désignion la désignation
pardon de référents dédiés à la
Fédération a été créée une adresse mail
dédiée
signalement@ffbb.com et une page
internet sur sur le site fédéral
comprenant les adresses de contact pour
l'accompagnement des victimes sur
laquelle l'allas est référencée le
signalement par la cellule du ministère
des
Sports outre les signalements directs de
victimes licencié ou de club les
services de la fédération œuvrent de
concert et très régulièrement avec la
transmission de signalement dont les
informations relatives au au au
prononcés de mesures d'incapacité ou
d'arrêté ou suspension d'exercice
euh si pardon vas-y vas-y je t'en prie
si vous souhaitez
les chiffres c'est peut-être ça qui vous
intéresse euh on a on a deux documents
on le premier document c'est la synthèse
de de lié à ce qu'on a traité au niveau
des la commission discipline comment ça
ét traité de la Chambre d'appel et
cetera et derrière vous avez la la la
globalité des dossiers ce qui concerne
les violences sexuelles par exemple et
nous avons ensuite une une liste de de
tous les dossiers traité ou en cours de
traitement pour 2022 2023 donc on peut
vous mettre à disposition l'ensemble de
ceses ces documents c'est c'est c'est
une il y a une si vous voulez qu'on
rentre dans le détail je peux vous
donner quelques exemples par exemple si
vous souhaitez donc là vous avez oui
très bien donc là vous avez tous les
dossiers et quelle suite vous y donnez
réellement
concrètement alors tous les tous les
par vous pouvez reprendre le micro
monsieur le
président dans le traitement des des
signalements euh ou directement de tout
ce qui est lié aux violences sexuelles
je pense que
c'est donc je je je lis si la Fédération
reçoit un signalement de violence
sexuelle en synthèse du
premier prise de contact on met en
relation si
l'accord de la personne remonte en effet
avec K c'est la première chose euh ce
que je vous dit tout à l'heure c'est que
le simple témoignage de la personne ne
suffit pas à déclencher une procédure
disciplinaire si souhait de ne pas
déposer plainte nous recherchons donc
des éléments complémentaires pour
permettre le cas échéant la fédération
de prendre toutes mesures visant
protéger licencié tout en respectant le
principe de présent sur l'innocence et
de respect de la vie privée si dépôt
d'une plainte par la victime dans le
cadre de la procédure judiciaire des
réceptions le référent prend tâche
auprès de l'officier de police judiciire
au préalable pour ne pas interférer dans
une enquête en cours des correspondances
auprès de procureur peuvent être adressé
en fonction des dossiers à la découverte
d'information susceptible de faire
l'objet d'une mesure conservatoire d'une
procédure disciplinaire la cellule
enquête pour obtenir des informations
plus précises sur l'identité de la
personne son rattachement à la
Fédération l'état la procédure et les
mesures d'incapacité éventuell déjà
prononcé dans le cas d'un jugement
prononcé si la personne est toujours
licenciée c'est ça qui est important
ouverture d'un dossier disciplinaire si
la personne n'est plus licenciée il est
indiqué dans la dans la fiche cette
fameuse outil métier FBI du licencier la
mention qualification interdite se
rapprocher du service juridique de la
Fédération on on essaie d'anticiper du
futur en cas d'une demande d'une
nouvelle licence dans le casre du pardon
redites-nous juste pour bien
comprendre une victime qui
souhaite soit faire part d'un témoignage
soit manifester un signalement vous vous
nous avez dit tout à l'heure il y a
quatre cellules quatre filières
possibles il y a il y a trois filières
possibles c'est ce qu'on au niveau du
signalement et toutes ces filières n
permettent de retomber au même endroit
dans lequel nous avons une cellule avec
ces ces quatre personnes dédiées ce sont
quatre quatre opérationnels et ensuite
donc c'est traité directement par notre
délégué référent donc vous avez votre
propre cellule plateforme vous avez
également la cellule du ministère signal
sport plus le plus clairement indiqué
identifié accessible à toute victime oui
tout à fait oui oui et la troisième vous
avez dit et on parle on parlait de voilà
en fait euh pardon je reprends euh il y
a il y a un un lien permanent euh de de
la cellule signalement de la Fédération
avec la cellule signalement du ministère
des Sports et avec Ka donc à ces trois
entités traitent ensemble des des des
affaires qui nous sont pour lequell nous
avons
l'information quand les signalements
partent de signal sport euh avez un
retour de signal sport oui directement
ça tombe dans la même ça tombe dans la
même la personne qui le référent
intégrité récupère l'intégralité des
informations et et les traites donc vous
êtes prévenu immédiatement quand il y a
un signalement signal sport vous êtes
prévenu immédiatement oui oui qui a eu
un signalement oui ok et euh et sur les
les différents types de signalement ça
concerne qui alors est-ce que par
exemple ça concerne des
entraîneurs des de la structure fédérale
est-ce que enfin voilà
c'est les signalements les notamment
pour
VSS qui sont en général les personnes
les auteurs présumés de tous ces faits
alors on reçoit tout on traite tout et
vous avez le détail ici de chaque fois
qu'on a un signalement vous avez le
détail ici sur les deux dernières années
chaque fois qu'on a eu un signalement
pour mettre à disposition ces documents
s quand même dire que majoritairement ce
sont des
entraîneurs de quel dispositif
permettant la libération de la parole
des victimes et leur accompagnement
dispose la
Fédération là encore la la la la
relation que nous avons avec Ka et la
convention que nous avons avec eux alors
s'agissant de encore une fois des
structures fédérales celles que nous
maîtrisons directement que sont le Pôle
France ou les pôles ir euh nous avons
euh très régulièrement en fait tous les
ans une sensibilisation qui est faite
soit par ka soit par la dragesse euh
pour que les les jeunes qui nous sont
confiés je le rappelle c'est important
pour nous euh des parents nous confient
leurs enfants et et et évidemment euh
c'est ce que je voulais vous dire dans
mon propos introductif mais pas assez
rapidement euh nous avons nous il est
essentiel pour nous que les parents
considèrent que les espaces euh et et
les les structures dans lesquelles ils
nous laissent les enfants sont des
structures sécurisées donc euh euh nous
faisons tous les ans de la prévention
auprès du public qui nous est confié au
sein des structures des structures
fédéral pour le reste c'est-à-dire les
clubs comme je vous le disais nous
faisons euh passer des notes très
régulièrement je vous ai je vous ai fait
je vous ai cité quelques notes qui
avaient été réalisées sur sur les
dernières années euh sur les derniers
mois euh auprès des des clubs de la
Fédération par l'intermédiaire de notre
intraînate
fédéral je peux juste quand on a par
exemple une une une décision contre un
entraîneur euh on a plus de facilité
pour pouvoir communiquer avec la
Fédération internationale que de
communiquer ses ses informations avec
les autres fédération au sein de au sein
du de notre propre territoire c'est
quand même assez assez surprenant je
pense que là il y a vraiment
amélioration en
faire moi je vais juste revenir un petit
peu en arrière sur les signalements
parce que je vous ai demandé justement
quelle catégorie de de personnes été
mise en cause vous m'avez dit
majoritairement des entraîneurs mais
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres catégories de
personnes qui ont déjà été mises en
cause sur des affaires de VSS ou autres
d'ailleurs euh dans les plaintes que
vous avez pu avoir à traiter sur les
signalement je oui parfois des
joueurs mais ils sont traités de la même
manière par par la Fédération par sa
commission de
discipline et je crois que nous avons eu
un dirigeant pour être précis voilà un
dirigeant de club je parle bien
sûr
Mo aussi un arbitre on un arbitre aussi
Qui est
concerné et donc personne par exemple au
niveau de la FD plus haut à votre
connaissance à ma connaissance
non le contrat de délégation mentionne
la désignation d'un référent et d'un
suppléant violence sexuelle c'est la
première fois que nous lisions qu'un
contrat prévoit un suppléant ces
personnes nont-elles été désignées et
pourquoi av avoir choisi de doubler le
référent d'un
suppléant
euh parce que nous considérions que
c'était important qu'il fallait mettre
les moyens humains qui qui étaient
nécessaires à la à la résolution de ces
affaires qui sont très compliquées et
qui nécessitent des échanges nombreux
qui
nécessitent de ne rien
échapper et et du coup d'où d'où cette
ce doublement du poste
oui il a dit je pense qu'il y a
énormément de travail il y a une volonté
de bien faire je crois qu'on est des
premiers fédération avoir fait ce ce
choix donc peut-être que demain on aura
de de suppléants en fonction des on
l'espère pas mais ça montre quand même
notre volonté de de traiter ce
dossier
alors moi je vais revenir aussi un tout
petit peu en arrière en 2019 l'ancienne
directrice de la Ligue féminine de
basketball a
quitté la Fédération est-ce que vous
pouvez revenir sur les raisons de son
départ et comment ça s'est
déroulé alors je vais le
faire il y avait une rupture de de de de
confiance entre nous entre entre elle et
moi elle est elle m'a informé que elle
partait dans une autre fédération euh la
fédération de natation en l'occurrence
euh et et
voilà just rajouter deux choses bon la
première
euh connaissant la directrice elle elle
a quand même fait du du bon travail il y
a eu très très peu de directrices de
cette ligue féminile avec une forte
volonté de de de développer et je sais
que chaque fois qu'elle a elle était é à
la recherche d' d'un travail bon c'est
toujours pareil les fédérations se
connaissent m'ont demander
personnellement ce que j'en connaissais
j'ai toujours dit du bien de de cette
directrice alors quand vous parlez de
rupture de confiance de quoi il s'agit
exactement nous n'étions pas en accord
sur sur ses missions et sur
sur voilà sur ses
missions donc vous dites qu'elle est
partie dans une autre fédération elle a
été enfin vous c'était une rupture
conventionnelle elle a été pas du tout
pas du tout c'est c'est une cadre d'État
donc elle s'est elle a été prise dans le
mouvement et elle a elle a été elle a
candidaté sur un autre poste au sein de
la Fédération Française de Natation euh
dans le cadre du mouvement classique et
euh et de la commission paritaire qui
s'est qui a statué sur ce sur ce
mouvement est-ce que vous proposez une
licence à tous vos
bénévoles tous les bénévoles même C
celui qui est au bar qui donne le coup
de main samedi soir pour un match c'est
une vraie vraie question
on on souhaiterait que tout le monde
soit licencié ça permet au moins de
protéger par rapport aux activités après
on sait que les les clubs font des choix
parce que ça coûte de l'argent même si
on fait depuis maintenant 3 ans une
tarriification spéciale pour
nouveauancier puisque c'est gratuit pour
les nouveaux les nouveaux encadrants
donc ensuite on essaie d'expliquer faire
la pédagogie important quand même que
tous les gens soient soi soi là puis bon
dans ce qu'on est en train de traiter
c'est important aussi puisquon peut les
suivre après on peut pas être derrière
tous les clubs on a près de 3 3800 clubs
c'est quand même très difficile donc
aujourd'hui on fait passer ces messages
on dit que c'est important et et très
souvent bon certains font le choix de
pas se licencier pour être peut-être un
peu plus à l'aise les activités donc
c'est très difficile mais on on rappelle
on rabâcheoi vous dites à l'aise dans
les activités ça veut dire quoi pour
être à l'aise dans les pe pouvoir
peut-être je je pensais pas mal quand je
disais ça est d'accord dessus non c'est
ben c'est tout simplement pas être lié à
un club c'està-d pas pas lier à un club
pas avoir à payer une une cotisation
parce que vous savez comment ça se passe
quand vous êtes dans un club vous avez
la la part fédérale la part régionale et
la part départemental mais aussi la
cotisation du club même si le club fa
peut faire des efforts financiers sur
les sur des encadrants donc voilà je
pense que on s'estaperçu qu'on a perdu
énormément de de de de bénévoles après
covid que les gens veulent plus s'en
metter avec ça on le sait très bien et
nous on essaie effectivement de de de de
de faire en sorte d'augmenter le nombre
de d'encadrant c'est important pour nous
et puis surtout qu'il soit
licencié vais ajouter à ça que si c'est
imposé dans dans nos statuts c'est
extrêmement compliqué à vérifier comme
l'a dit le
président pour ma part et sur la partie
projet de performance fédérale les
sélections départemental régional
nationale qui sont au contact de jeunes
de mineurs l'ensemble des encadrants
doivent être évidemment
licencié en
2020 Valérie
elle donc ancienne joueuse de basket
aorté plainte contre son ancien
entraîneur Ludovic Pouillard pour des
faits de viol sur mineur qui aurait eu
lieu en 2002 la préfecture a interdit à
Monsieur Pouillard d'exercer auprès de
mineurs et vous aviez également pris des
mesures conservatoires en CE sens en
2023 comment expliquer que cette
interdiction soit arrivée si tardivement
alors que visiblement de nombreuses
personnes au sein du club était au
courant au moment des faits de cette
relation et qu'une réunion avait été
organisée à ce sujet la Fédération
n'avait-elle pas eu de remonter à ce
momentlà si vous voulez bien je vais
revenir sur sur les faits et procédures
euh le 21 mars
2021 ka nous informe le ministère des
Sports et la Fédération d'une plainte
déposée
par Valérie lelle contre Monsieur
Pouillard pour des faits de viol en 2002
et 2003 la victime présumée était
mineure au moment des faits et joueuse
d'unô l'espoir avril juuillet 2021
relance des services de l'État par la
Fédération transfert de dossier de
Monsieur Pouillard entre différentes
régions parce que la difficulté que nous
avons rencontré dans ce dans ce dossier
est le fait que cette personne a a
régulièrement changé de région et ce qui
nous a obligé à régulièrement faire des
courriers au procureur de la République
le 23 août 2021 courrier de la
Fédération au procureur de la République
de Pontoise relative à une information
d'ouverture d'enquête judiciaire contre
à l'encontre de Monsieur Pouillard le 2
septembre 2021 courrier du procureur de
la République du tribunal judiciaire de
Pontoise informant la Fédération de la
transmission au Parquet enquête de
Strasbourg au fin de poursuite de
l'enquête préliminaire 15 décembre 2021
courrier du procureur de la République
du tribunal judiciaire de Strasbourg
informant la Fédération que le dossier a
été retourné au parquet de
camp territorialement
compétent 30 septembre 2022 courrier de
la Fédération au procureur de la
République de cand 30 novembre 2022 mise
en examen de Monsieur Pouillard bureau
fédéral des 3 août des 3 pardon euh 3 et
8 février 2023 mesure administrativ
conservatoire d'interdiction d'exercice
de l'activité d'éducateur sportif
entraîneur dirigeant auprès des mineurs
1er mars 2023 suspension de ses
fonctions auprès de l'équipe
professionnelle par orchésien
basket alors j'entends la chronologie et
le fait que ça ait changé de région à
plusieurs reprises mais qu'est-ce qui
empêcher la Fédération euh d'ouvrir une
une mesure disciplinaire ou ou sanction
à titre conservatoire dès
2021 ma question c'était plutôt pourquoi
ça arrive en 2023 alors que il y avait
une une enfin voilà un renvoi
d'instruction permanent entre les
différentes régions et que voilà c'est
pourquoi il y a eu ces 2 ans de délis en
fait d'abord je vous l'ai dit le suivi
du dossier a étéit très complexe pour la
fédération parce
que pour les pour des causes de
transfert du dossier administratif et
pénal de Monsieur de la personne en
question entre l'île-de-fance le grand
est la Normandie et les Haut-
defance évidemment ça a généré des
allongements de de de prise de contact
et des temps de réponses par rapport à
à à à cette à ce dossier le préfet n'
prononcer une mesure d'urgence une
mesure en urgence que le 6 mars
2023 alors en fait moi ce que je vous
demande c'est pas voilà moi ce que je
vais reposer la question moi ce que je
vous demande c'est pas ce qu'a fait le
préfet ni la justice c'est ce que fait
la Fédération et en fait à partir du
moment où vous aviez eu connaissance de
la plainte vous auriez pu faire un
mesure disciplinaire à titre
conservatoire sans attendre ni la
décision du préfet ni celle de la
justice et en fait c'est c'est ça ma
question c'est pourquoi vous il se passe
2 ans avant finalement que vous
suspentiez parce qu'il y aurait pu avoir
d'autres victimes entre
alors il me semble qu'il n'était pas au
courant de la plainte et que nous ne
pouvions pas interférer dans dans dans
une démarche qui était une démarche de
de mais en 2021 vous avez écrit donc
vous étiez au courant de la plainte vous
étiez informé dès 2021 lui n'était pas
au courant de la plainte je vous parle
pas de nous je vous parle de lui
visiblement mais oui mais moi je mais
que lui soit pas informé j'ai envie de
dire c'est enfin vous votre votre sujet
à vous c'est vous êtes informé qu'il y a
une plainte on peut nuire à la procédure
mesure alors qu'il y a une procédure en
cours et c'est exactement la démarche
qui nous a guidé exactement la démarche
qui nous a guidé mais est-ce qu'on vous
a demandé est-ce que la justice vous a
demandé explicitement de ne pas faire de
mesures conservatoir ou disciplinaire
pour ne pas nuir à
l'enquête je pense que oui je pense que
oui ce alors
noniss voilà vous avez un écrit et voilà
quelque chose de formel soit ça va être
compliqué
sûr c'est que le le la personne était
pas au courant qu'il était sur sous
enquête
donc je pense qu'on a dû être je vais
vérifier sur maffiche on a dû être à un
moment donné on nous a dû demander de
pas euh de pas ouvrir un dossier
disciplinaire vis-à-vis de lui ou des
mesures dans ce dossier-là nous avons
travaillé en pleine en pleine
connaissance avec les instances
judiciaires les services de l'État et et
les faits remontant à plus de 20 ans le
le le la plainte n'étant pas connue par
par la personne concernée euh je ne peux
vous dire que sans doute nous
attons engagé ou encouragé à à à suivre
cette procédure plus généralement euh je
le redis parce que je je je vous l'ai
dit et je je je maintiens ça nous
travaillons en étroite collaboration
permanente avec la cellule du ministère
et Capa et et et dans ce cas-là les
instances
judiciaires je je
oui non c'est bon non non mais en fait
ça on comprend tout à fait la relation
de travail qui existe entre le ministère
l'association colos au pied d'argile et
le volet judiciaire sauf que vous le
savez parfois les enquêes peuvent
prendre énormément de temps et justement
la possibilité des fédérations de
pouvoir prendre des sanctions
disciplinaires à à titre conservatoire
permettent parfois de mettre à l'écart
un auteur présumé de potentiell autres
victimes sur des pratiqu Sportiv en tout
cas sur vos sur les équipements où il y
a des pratiques sportives et donc tout
l'enjeu pour nous aujourd'hui si vous
voulez vous vous avez en procédure
disciplinaire Vous avez jusqu'à 10
semaines de délis pour prendre une
décision la justice ça peut être 2 ans 3
ans 4 ans ça peut être très long donc
voilà la question en fait et c'est très
différent c'est pour ça que c'est aussi
intéressant d'entendre plusieurs
fédérations c'est que c'est vraiment
très différent d'une fédération à
l'autre il y en a qui le font
systématiquement et il y en a qui font
d'autres choix et ce qu'on essaie de
comprendre c'est pourquoi en fait ces
choix sont si différents d'une
fédération à l'autre alors j'entend que
parfois ça peut être pour de panuir à
l'enquête mais dans ces cas-là en
général la justice fait une demande
explicite et et donc on peut le
comprendre mais là alors du coup on sait
pas trop et par ailleurs l'interdiction
d'ex elle est uniquement auprès de
mineur voilà donc aujourd'hui vous la la
décision qui est
prise je sais pas peut-être vous pouvez
nous dire exactement quelle sanction a
été prise par la fédération en tant que
T est-ce que c'est aussi juste auprès de
mineur ou est-ce que c'est tout public
voilà est-ce qu'il entraîne toujours
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il est à proximité
d'un public comment ça se passe
aujourd'hui
alors c'est un cas extrêmement particul
effectivement
euh il ne peut pas reprendre de licence
au sein de la fédération donc il n'est
plus licencié de la fédération et il ne
peut pas en reprendre il ne peut pas en
reprendre c'est une mesure
administrative Conservatoire il lui est
interdit d'encadrer des mineurs et
pourtant il est toujours salarié d'un
club de basket en tant que manager
général évidemment
euh ça ne nous a pas satisfait et ça ne
nous satisfait pas mais c'est une
situation qui est
extrêmement compliqué d'autant plus que
nous nous sommes constitués partie civil
dans ce dossier et que nous n'avons
toujours pas eu de retour par rapport à
cette constitution de partie civile donc
nous n'avons pas
accès bien évidemment aux éléments de
l'enquête qui pourrait qui pourrait
euh qui pourrait nous éclairer
euh nous savons que le comité
d'administration le conseil
d'administration du club a décidé de le
maintenir contre la vie du président en
place à l'époque et que ce dernier a
démissionné aujourd'hui il il peut être
manager général d'un club sans être
licencié de la fédération et dès lors
qu'il n'approche pas et qu'il n'encadre
pas de
mineur j'essaie de traduire et de
comprendre donc il y a une décision qui
est prise par le préfet vous prenez
aussi une décision au niveau de la FD
voilà il ne peut plus avoir de licence
il est quand même recruté par un club il
est maintenu contre laave du président
du club qui décide de démissionner
aujourd'hui il est pas licencié mais il
est quand même salarié du club et donc
qui contrôle qu'il est pas à proximité
de mineur ou qu'il ne se passera rien
dans ce club est-ce que par exemple la
Fédération vous avez pris à tâche avec
ce club pour en savoir plus et euh et
pour demander justement pourquoi il a
été maintenu malgré la décision de la
Fédération de ne plus accorder de
licence juste peut-être pour préciser la
décision de ne plus de ne plus avoir
licence c'est le préfet ou c'est la
fédération qui la prend la décision
administrative parce que le préfet moi
de ce que je comprends
euh attendez je retrouve c'est l'exercer
c'est l'interdiction d'exercer auprès
des
mineurs donc ensuite visiblement vous
nous dites qu'il y a une interdiction de
prendre une
licence pour répondre à votre première
question
euh d'abord sachez qu'il y a eu une
demande de conciliation de de la part
euh de de Monsieur Pouillard par rapport
à la décision qui a été prise par la
Fédération euh et cette conciliation euh
a proposé de s'en tenir à la décision
contestée par par par l'individu euh
l'avocat de de Monsieur pard a formé un
recours en annulation devant le tribunal
administratif de Paris
euh il y a une enquête pénale enc nous
ne voulions pas vraiment interférer euh
dans ces dans ces dans cette enquête
euh et
euh je voulais revenir sur quel ça
j'entends alors ah oui pardon nous avons
sol alors du coup la question donc en
fait donc pendant les 2 ans il y avait
une enquête en cours donc vous n'avez
pas souhaité interférer donc pendant les
2 ans qu'est-ce qu'il faisait il était
au club d'orchie mais toujours auprès de
mineur non non exclusivement des
adultes si si je peux me permettre on a
on a demandé alors du coup la question
c'est comment s'est vérifié qu'il est
pas en contact par qu'on a demandé parce
qu'on a demandé à la SD Jes 59 d'aller
faire un contrôle administratif sur
place pour vérifier les les
les alors un contrôle en 2 ans c'est ça
enfin 2021 2023 oui euh on sait comment
ça se passe dans un club vous avez des
mineurs et des majeurs qui qui circulent
librement
sans obligatoirement décliner un
parcours clairement identifié donc
évidemment que ce monsieur é en contact
de mineur on ne peut que le constater
même s'il y a un contrôle qui est fait
sur place vous le
savez pardon
[Musique]
euh le contrôle qui est fait par la
csdjs 59 quand on a le retour il nous
exprime que il n'exerce aucune fonction
mentionnée à à l'article
l2121 auprès de mineur l'enquête
administrative est toujours en cours
voilà la réponse que nous avons
eu et juste sur la question de la
licence donc qui prend la décision c'est
nous c'est nous c'est bien s bien sûr
d'acord et depuis la démission du
président sur le club donc est-ce que
vous avez pris à tâche avec le conseil
d'administration qui a pris la décision
de maintenir cette personne dans le club
pour savoir et pour peut-être les
informer de la situation s'il n'étit pas
au courant est-ce qu'il y a eu
l'élection d'un nouveau président sur ce
club une élection nouveau Président je
pense je pense que oui je peux pas vous
confirmer mais il peut pas y avoir un
club sans sans président ensuite je
pense que notre délégintégrité suit
comme tous les tous les dossiers et
compris celui-là donc eu une relation
avec le club voilà après ce que ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'on est l'enquête
administrative est toujours en cours et
qu'à priori aujourd'hui il encadre pas
ou il est pas en relation avec des avec
des mineurs c'est ce qu' nous ont dit
pardon c'est un club professionnel qui
n'a pas de centre de
formation une question de notre collègue
claudiaarou
oui oui parce que là enfin je je je
trouve un peu sidérant que qui est pas
une mise à pied immédiate hier on en a
parlé avec la Fédération d'athelet moi
je connais un président de club qui a eu
des doutes pas même plus que des doutes
puisqu'il avait des preuves sur des SMS
qui a mis immédiatement à pied et
licencié vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
d'une rupture conventionnelle vous
auriez très bien pu au minimum proposer
une rupture conventionnelle quand il y
avait vraiment des doutes sur une
personne vis-à-vis d'enfant est-ce que
la fédération parce que vous vous rendez
compte quand même que des affaires comme
ça ça vous entachche un peu voilà alors
est-ce qu'à un moment donné quand un
président démissionne parce qu'il se
refuse à recruter une personne comme
Monsieur Pouillot est-ce que à un moment
donné la Fédération enage engage la
responsabilité du conseil
d'administration ou du bureau et du
nouveau ou de la nouvelle présidente du
club en disant voilà vous êtes informé
de ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui la
Fédération portera plinte ou en tout cas
euh se dégage de toute responsabilité
vous assumerez votre choix est-ce que ça
vous le faites
ça
Vy pardon je vais y arriver ils ont
suspendu leur coach cette cette décision
a été attaquée par l'avocat de de la
personne concernée
euh ensuite et tant que l'affaire n'est
pas terminée il est présumé
innocent il est présumé innocent donc en
l'état actuel du droit je ne vois pas
comment la Fédération peut se peut
dépasser son son cadre législatif on le
on on on on
on alors juste contre le contre la
personne oui pas contre le club
ou plus qu'une mesure conservatoire
contre la personne puisque puisque on a
enfin il y a une mesure conservatoire
contre la personne puisquelle a été
prise par le bureau par le Bureau oui
mais qui n'arrive qu'en
j'entends bien sûr par contre juste une
question du coup sauf si allez-y
termininez puis je on peut prendre une
mesure conservatoire et retirer une
licence à une une à une personne c'est
le cas clairement nous on le considère
comme n'étant
pas licencier de la Fédération enfin on
fait plus que le considère considéré il
ne l'est pas clairement
oui mais excusez-moi je peux madame la
Présidente
oui oui bien sûr merci oui justement ça
ça paraît quand même incroyable que dans
des clubs hein moi je connais aussi des
grands clubs de de basket où chaque
dirigeant euh est licencié c'est des
licences dirigeantes surtout que vous
avez fait des efforts sur la gratuité
comment comment se fait-il que vous
n'imposiez pas manager général d'un club
que cette personnelà soit licenciée
enfin ça paraît incroyable c'est pas le
le le petit jeune qui encadre une équipe
de Poussin ou enfin de moins de moins de
10 ou non c'est le manager général et
avez-vous un moment donné à penser à
imposer parce que là c'est une personne
qui est rémunérée que toute personne
d'ailleurs rémunéré dans un club soit
licencié parce que sinon il y a pas de
moyen effectivement on entend on a
entendu ça avec d'autres fédération
oui c une bonne question je p qu'il faut
qu'on regarde si si derrière on a cette
capacité d'obliger à ce que tout tout
salarié d'un club de prè de l'OM soit
soit effectivement licencier de la
fédération et comment on peut l'imposer
comment on peut le contrôler mais oui
alors moi si je peux me permettre juste
pour vraiment pour comprendre entre le
moment où la plainte est déposée et donc
le préfet prend la décision enfin je
sais plus trop en quel année et jusqu'en
2023 est-ce que vous vous avez pris à
tâche avec le club pour les prévenir euh
que cette personne qui était encore en
poste chez eux euh bah a qu' y avait eu
une plainte qui avait été déposée est-ce
que vous est-ce qu'il y a eu des
contacts avec le
club personnellement non je pense pas
que que
derrière au niveau de la gouvernance
nous avons été concernés par des
contacts directs il faut effectivement
voir si notre délégué intégrité a fait
ça je pense qu'il le fait comme
raisonant tous les clubs donc je peux
vous amener cette confirmation par
Laprès alors c'est c'est c'est là où en
fait c'est compliqué c'est-à-dire que il
y a une plainte qui a déposée en 2021 le
club n'est même pas informé que la
personne qui est chez eux a une plainte
dessus enfin une plainte pour viol sur
mineur et et d'ailleurs je peux vous
lire he parce que c'est dans la presse
le président du club dit on a découvert
les accusations comme tout le monde en
lisant les articles on a reçu un
courrier de la FFB il y a une semaine
donc le vendredi 24 février rien avant
pendant 2 ans en fait il était dans le
club et personne ne savait ce qui se
passait je crois qu'en l'état du droit
nous n'avons pas le droit de le faire
dès lors que il y a une plainte déposée
donc c'est à c'est à vérifier je je je
on reviendra vers vous mais en fait si
vous pouvez prendre une mesure
conservatoire parce qu'il y a des
plaintes vous pouvez informer le club
quand même contre un contre un licencié
et et nous ne nous avons un devoir par
rapport il é licencié 20 par on prend on
prend une décision vis-à-vis d'un
licencié et cette
décision n'est pas communiquée
effectivement mais je je le
redis je pense qu'en l'état actuel du
droit il faut une décision de justice
pour que on puisse informer le club je
rappelle que ce club est une société en
fait moi je c'est là où j'ai un peu de
mal à comprendre parce que il est
licencié salarié de du club vous avez
connaissance de la
plainte vous pouvez tout à fait réunir
une enfin une commission de discipline
et décider de le suspendre vous avez pas
besoin d'une décision de justice pour ça
une fois qu'il est suspendu par la
Fédération vous informez le club qu'il
est suspendu donc je comprends pas
pourquoi en fait vous pouvez pas
prévenir le club de ce en fait c'est ça
moi je les 2 ans de battement j'arrive
pas à les
comprendre et juste pour ajouter on a
entendu une fédération qui quand il y a
un signalement dans un club hein
systématiquement c'est la fédération qui
suspend bien évidemment en accord avec
le président du club
même si la plainte est en cours même si
la personne n'est pas informée c'est
suspension immédiate on a entendu ça de
fédération donc pourquoi ça ne
s'appliquerait pas à toutes les
fédérations encore une fois il est
suspendu cette personne n'a plus de
licence de la Fédération Française de
BasketBall il est suspendu j'entends
bien sur les 2 ans effectivement je
comprends je comprends par rapport aux 2
années effectivement et et je je je n'ai
pas la réponse si ce n'est
qu'effectivement il a été difficile à
suivre puisqu'il a changé beaucoup de
clubs et euh et euh alors je vous avoue
que je n'ai plus en tête exactement
quand il est arrivé dans le club d'orchi
très précisément j'ai pas la date exacte
euh mais je sais et c'est ce que 2022
2023 alors saison 2022 2023 il est
arrivé à orchi ce que je sais c'est que
nous avons systématiquement communiqué
dès lors que nous savions qu'il
changeait euh de club c'est ce que je
vous disais en et communiquer auprès de
qui pas auprès des clubs du coup auprès
du préfet voilà et donc alors c'est
c'est là où en fait pour moi il y a une
vraie difficulté c'està-dire que les
clubs sont pas informés moi je vous dis
franchement euh et je le souhaite pas
mais j'espère qu'il y a pas de victime
entre 2021 et 2023 parce que les clubs
n'étaient pas informés en fait et c'est
c'est là en fait je comprends que vous
l'avez suspendu en 2023 mais pourquoi il
y a pas eu de suspension immédiate en
2021 quand vous avez eu connaissance de
la
plante
donc
oui en fait ce qu'il faudrait c'est que
malgré le fait
que l'enquête soit en cours et qu'il
faut être discret et cetera il faudrait
que nous fédérations de façon
orale on puisse informer donc les clubs
respectifs qu'on fasse directement vous
pensez une mesure conservatoire mais
vous en avez le pouvoir en fait vous en
avez le pouvoir immédiatement dès que
vous avez connaissance de la plainte
vous pouvez suspendre à titre
conservatoire
oui collèg Stéphane bchou merci madame
la
Présidente non juste dans j'avais pas
forcément prévu de d'intervenir mais
mais c'est vrai que
le les derniers échanges me font me font
réagir bon je m'inscris évidemment dans
dans tout ce qu'il vient de dire moi je
suis un peu surpris effectivement que de
la chronologie des enfin non seulement
enfin de la chronologie des faits eu
égard à la gravité des
faits et euh bon il suffit de de
alors c'est vrai qu'on a été là aussi
parfois surpris de
la d'une certaine forme de
méconnaissance de de des droits et
devoirs au sein des fédérations et et et
on en a ici
l'illustration de la même manière
qu'hier dans un autre dans une autre
audition nous avons confirmé à un
président de fédération française qu'il
était habilité à déclencher un article
40 visiblement il n'était pas informé
bon donc je pense que de ce point de vue
là enfin nous nous sommes aussi là pour
identifier comme son nom
l'indique les dysfonctionnement au sein
des Fédération Française je pense que là
on a mis le doigt sans faire de mauvais
jeux de mots sur un grave
dysfonctionnement et donc je je pense
qu'il est urgent de de de vraiment
prendre toute la mesure des droits et
devoirs en terme de responsabilités qui
sont qui sont les
vôtres donc moi aussi je m'étonne
évidemment de enfin je m'étonne et le
mot est faible de du fait que bah il est
fallu tout ce temps
pour pour prendre la mesure de de de de
ce qui s'était
passé informer le préfet oui informer le
préfet enfin on voit bien que c'est
c'est d'une c'est d'une efficacité toute
toute relative et au fond ma question
c'est contenu de ce qui vient de se
passer peut-on être assuré que si demain
cela se reproduisait aux mêmes causees
nous n'aurions pas les mêmes effets et
je crains que la réponse soit un peu
dans la
question
je vous en prie monsieur le Président je
rappelle que nous ne sommes pas bien sûr
au tribunal hein nous sommes juste là
comme l'a dit notre collègue Stéphane
bichchou bon c'est un sujet c'est
compliqué moi j'ai j'ai j'ai vraiment
confiance à au service opérationnel la
Fédération bon on est mont l'exemple
très souvent donc c'est si ce sujet on
n'est pas capable tous les deux
l'expliquer c'est qu'il est quand même
vraiment pas simple ce ce ce il a
certainement violé un jeune mais
aujourd'hui il est pas condamné euh il a
changé le club tous les ans c'est nous
qui avons mobilisé donc les services de
l'État pour pouvoir poursuivre dirais
cette cette cette situation quand même
euh ensuite si on doit euh nous
systématiquement prend une mesure je
dirais de de sauvegarde chaque fois
qu'on a entendu euh je dirais un fait
qui n'est pas confirmé
puisqueaujourd'hui il il est présumé
innocent euh on on risque d'avoir un
retour des euh des des des je dirais des
des situations ou des recours difficiles
donc euh c'est un vrai sujet faisant-le
par je dirais par euh par précaution
systématiquement bon euh alors juste
peut-être là-dessus si vous vous nous
dites présemp son d'innocence bien sûr
pour le moment pourquoi à votre avis
pourquoi il changeait régulièrement de
club si si juste je peux vous mentionner
quelque chose c'est qu'on a quand même
changé la procédure en 2022 on s'est
bien rendu compte qu'effectivement il y
avait il y av avait euh
euh ce souci de rapidité qui était
absolument à à prendre en considération
et que et que nous devions nous devions
euh justement réagir réagir ça ouvre une
autre voie et une autre voie qui est
celle de de de la protection de la
Fédération parce que euh euh
euh parce que systématiquement
euh c'est type de personne peut-être va
être représenté par un avocat qui peut
pousser la Fédération sur un contentieux
contentieux que on n'est pas certain de
de gagner parce qu'on va au-delà de
notre de notre des règles de droit voilà
donc je je je c'est un élément qui est
un élément important à mon sens parce
que ce risque là on le prend ce que je
veux vous dire c'est que ce risque là on
le prend et depuis 2022 en ayant modifié
nos procédures on a on a pleinement pris
conscience des choses je rajouterait que
que on
a on a
eu tous à à à comment dire on a tous
pris conscience de ça véritablement et
et je pense que les fédérations
sportives en règle générale j'entends ce
que vous disiez sur un président de
fédération mais mais tout le monde a
conscience dans le mouvement sportif et
et nous à la Fédération de Française de
Basket je pense vraiment en particulier
et on le disait tout à l'heure
pour nous la sécurité de nos pratiquants
est
essentielle madame la députée l'a dit ça
atteint l'image de d'une discipline
sportive et d'une fédération sportive il
n'en est pas question pour nous
clairement clairement donc il peut y
avoir nous devons sans doute améliorer
les dispositifs c'est une évidence c'est
une évidence j'imagine que je j'espère
en tout cas votre travail va va le
permettre mais on a aussi besoin d'être
sécurisé par rapport à ça et ça veut
dire que ça passe par la voie
législative
je si vous me le permettez moi je je
c'est très intéressant parce que encore
une fois je pense que là on est au cœur
du problème et et je redis parce que
c'est important de le redire à chaque
fois qu'il chaque fois qu'il est
nécessaire de le redire et je vais le
faire que nous ne sommes pas un tribunal
que nous ne sommes ni procureur ni juge
nous sommes ici pour clairement
identifier les dysfonctionnements et
essayer de trouver à terme des solution
et donc ces discussions là qui
sont
directes je pense doiv permettre
d'améliorer vous avez raison quand vous
dites nous sommes là pour assurer la
sécurité de nos pratiquants mais en
disant cela
euh
vous vous enfin ce qui ce qui vient de
se passer démontre qu'au fond le droit
et je suis très attaché au droit le
droit prend parfois le dessus sur la
sécurité des pratiquants je je
j'illustre ce ce propos je vous écoutais
avec attention tout à l'heure et vous
disez mais ou il y a la présomption
d'innocence ici dans cette salle nous
sommes particulièrement attaché au
présomption la présomption d'innocence
qui est un un totem fond enfin un totem
qui qui est fondamental dans notre
Constitution bon euh en revanche alors
vous disiez aussi il y a le risque de
contentieux justement mais
entre le risque de
contentieux et le risque de
récidive de quelqu'un qui certes n'est
pas condamné mais qui fait l'objet d'un
dépôt de plainte alors moi j'entends
qu'il faut sécuriser par par des
éléments législatifs bon ça ça c'est
c'est je dirais c'est notre travail on
va on va regarder comment est-ce qu'on
peut là aussi étayer tout
cela mais
euh oui moi je pense que vous auriez dû
et encore une fois je le dis là et c'est
certainement plus facile de le dire
aujourd'hui mais vous auriez dû par
quelques moyen que ce soit informer les
clubs faire une diffusion très large des
agissements de ce
monsieur parce que en faisant en ne le
faisant
pas en ne le faisant pas et en vous
pardon de le dire comme ça mais en vous
cachant derrière la présomption
d'innocence voyez aujourd'hui vous êtes
un peu dans la NAS et et en échangeant
vous compte que bah oui c'est donc
[Musique]
essayons collectivement là de de trouver
les leviers de manière à ce que dès le
dépôt de plainte
euh on puisse avoir une une
mesure qui qui peut s'arrêter à un
moment euh si il est avéré
que qu' y a pas de euh que que les faits
sont sont pas ne sont pas réels et juste
euh pardon mais pour illustrer ça toutes
choses égales par ailleurs et toutes
proportion gardé regardez ce qui se
passe en ce moment il y a il y a une
inform enfin il y a il y a personne
assez médiatique qui déferit la
chronique pour des faits un peu
similaires je n'ai aucune connaissance
de la de l'a faire dans le détail et
cetera et cetera mais il se trouve que
c'est quelqu'un qui fait de la radio et
ben dès cette après-midi il est pas à
l'antenne il est suspendu d'antenne